its e3 2015 you're watching gamespot I'm
Dan Hines and i'm here with peter brown
hey you just saw an extended demo of the
Last Guardian yeah yeah very exciting
what happened ok so the demo we saw last
night is about ninety percent of what I
saw but they also showed what happened
right before the gameplay that we know
we saw during the presentation so
essentially you the boy and treecko the
animal wake up in these ruins and from
what I could tell they're trying to form
a relationship together to escape it
didn't seem like they knew one another
and so Treecko had some thorns in its
back it's that classic tale of you know
pulling the thorn out of the lion's paw
so once the boy did that then he was
able to you know work with Treecko to
solve puzzles and at first it was sort
of strange because you didn't really
know what the object was in the game in
order to proceed but the boy picked up a
barrel and that God treecko's attention
like you know a dog or a cat might get
excited about a toy that you pick up so
once he kind of threw one or two those
two Treecko and got his interest Chico
then started to look for more and that
led him to stand up on a balcony and the
boy could climb his back then he went up
over the balcony on the other side
opened a gate and then we saw the two
outside with the demo that we saw
yesterday okay it seems like the animal
does actually know more about the
environment than the boy do you get a
sense of what is actually happening or
has happened in this world through had
the way the animal reacts to things it's
really difficult to tell but for me
towaway de the creator of this game the
creative director also of you go and
shout out the Colossus was talking about
how his games always involve a lot of
height and so Treecko is an animal who
because he allows you to sort of get
around these these obstacles that deal
with height and depth he is your your
confidence man right he's there to sort
of be your support as the player and
it's difficult to tell where these two
characters originated from at the moment
yeah my impression that I got from it
was that it seemed like quite a scripted
sequence the gameplay demo minutes in
charity right you compare it to
something like shadow of the colossus
where you're just in an environment
there's your target and then you just
have to go climate and kill it what what
what do you think is is going to happen
like going forward I mean like was this
this typical controlled demo or are we
going to see more kind of interactions
that aren't you know on these kinds of
rail
well it's less on Rails and I think it
first appears because remember the
example when the boy jumped and treecko
caught him right the second time he did
it Treecko miss and he caught the tail
yes that looked like a cut scene but
during the demo it was an accident a way
to playing the game actually mr.
grabbing the tail so you have to do that
with proper timing and it said I guess
it's like a quick time event but there's
no button prompt right so it's a very
like organic process of you know working
with the world and doing these things as
they appear I don't know how the game is
going to play out obviously because
you've only seen this little bit but it
seems to be that you are in control of
everything and frankly the game it looks
wonderful yeah this these games are very
minimalist in terms of you know just
visual style and mechanics as well do
you think we're going to see something
like shadow of the colossus as strength
meter when you're actually climbing on
Treecko do you think we'll have a danger
of falling off him oh yes you can
totally fall off like a way to fell off
and fell to the pit and the game was
like you got to start over but it wasn't
the same thing where you only have so
much strength you literally just missed
that moment so that a lot of that
remains to be seen but you know it's so
much about the relationship and the
interaction communication between these
two characters so I think that more than
anything is going to be the primary
mechanic cool so did this make you more
excited for it or did give you more
insight to it than you know we all have
yes very excited by it of course Jen
design is the team working on it which
Japan studio and Jen design is I found
out today is made up of members
primarily who worked on Tameka that is
the guys who made eco and shout other
classes so it's in really good hands it
seems to borrow from both of those games
and that said I'm very excited awesome
alright for more on the Last Guardian
stay tuned to gamespot com
you